okay welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
unmute and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in q a session
at the end
second today's gdpr seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host ishan
kujakar who is a phd candidate in the
electrical and computer engineering
department at university of florida
advised by professor joelle harley
his research interests include
probabilistic machine learning
uncertainty uncertainty quantification
acoustic signal processing
structural health monitoring and
surrogate modeling ishan holds a
master's in
electrical engineering from texas a m
university
and a bachelor's degree in electronics
engineering from
bits pilani in india
today ishan will talk about uncertainty
aware
guided wave structural health monitoring
using ensembl learning now without
further ado let me pass the button to
ishan by asking a random question as
usual
that is
today's random question uh let's try to
be fun what is your supernatural power
if you have any
uh
sometimes i have the
tunnel syndrome i don't i don't
understand what is happening in in in my
surroundings when i'm trying to focus on
something
i i think a lot of people might have
that
but that is something i think that's
unique for me very focused when you
yeah
okay so my daughter has that
that power as well all right thank you
so stage is yours
hi um thank you yongsu for inviting me
today
uh
i'm very excited to talk about my
research uh today uh and so let's start
i'm going to be talking about
uncertainty aware machine learning for
structural health monitoring
so
uh here's a brief outline of what i will
be talking about i will introduce what
structural health monitoring means i
will talk about guided wave sensing
approaches for shm then i will talk
about uh damage detection and damage
localization approaches and what are my
contributions
and finally i will i will conclude this
task so i hope that all of you find
something interesting learn something
new today from this talk
so structural health monitoring why is
it important why should we care about it
in recent times we are using a lot of
buildings aeroplanes bridges roadways
etc and this has led to a necessity to
monitor their condition
traditionally we have non-destructive
testing methods
where a person actually goes and
inspects those structures
but this needs a person to be actually
doing that inspection and that is costly
and time consuming so another approach
to this is called a structural health
monitoring shm in short and what is shm
is you have an array of sensors that is
permanently mounted on this structure
and then based on the received signals
you apply some signal processing
techniques to detect the damage that is
uh tell if there is a damage in the
first place and then localize the damage
find the location of that damage
so
even though there is a lot of research
on structural health
monitoring why is it difficult we see a
lot of research that is not translated
into actual industrial applications
so what are the challenges that we have
here
most importantly uncertainty so no
matter whatever application we have
there is going to be some uncertainty
that could be uncertainty due to the
sensor noise or due to some incomplete
knowledge about the underlying physical
process
so i like to go with this uh kind of
distinction
in scientific application you need to
understand the uncertainty
so let's say you're studying certain
physical phenomena you need to find a
way to quantify what is the uncertainty
in your variable of interest
whereas if you're working with
engineering applications you need to
manage the uncertainty
that is let's say you're working with
some system you want to
ensure that the system performs reliably
even when there is uncertainty
so what happens in a sensing application
that is you haven't you have a setup of
sensors that are placed and these
sensors are recording some signals you
need to analyze some something from
those sensor signals
so you have this uncertainty at the
sensor level you also have the
uncertainty at the output level
so my point here is no matter whatever
our
research areas are
we
have to deal with uncertainty and how we
deal with that is based on our
application of interest
and in my presentation i will talk about
hi how
i am
working with uncertainty in my research
area
so with that
let's talk up talk a bit about guided
wave sensing so guided wave setup is a
popular approach for structural health
monitoring
and what it is is basically you have a
structure there is a damage at some
point that needs to be identified for
that you place an array of sensors on
this structure
and these sensors then transmit and
receive guided waves
and based on the receive waves you do
some signal processing analysis to
either detect damage or localize damage
so the received signals at the sensors
are a combination of two signals so one
is the direct signal that is traveling
directly from the transmitter to the
receiver and the second is the damage
signal that is traveling from the
transmitter to the damage and then to
the receiver
so for for the application what we need
to do is subtract away the baseline that
is the direct path signal so we are only
left with the damage signal
and the advantages of using guided wave
setup is it is sensitive to damage it
also has a large scanning range
but there are certain challenges too
the underlying physics of wave
propagation is complicated you need to
be developing the appropriate
mathematical models to deal with that
secondly you also have external
variations such as
snowfall rainfall that lead to
temperature variations and this also
affects the wave propagation
so uh the common model used for guided
waves is called as a lam wave model
it was developed by a british
mathematician physicist
and uh the
x that is the frequency domain
representation
uh at a particular frequency omega and
at a distance r
is given by this summation over n wave
modes
so every wave mode can be considered as
a
distinct signal component so your wave
is made up of multiple such wave modes
and the the term that we see in the
square root the kappa that's the wave
number so the kappa is dependent on the
mode n and the frequency omega
so this uh this wave number frequency
relationship is captured in the
dispersion curves and this is why the
wave exhibits dispersive behavior
so it can happen that at a particular
frequency the wave is traveling in two
different modes
and the wave velocity can also be
calculated by the inverse slope of the
dispersion curve
so uh on the left side we see dispersion
curves so i have
illustrated two modes here s0 mode and
a0 mode those are the prominent modes
that researchers work with for guided
waves
and these these lead to the simulated
waveform that we see on the right you
see the s0 mode occurring first followed
by the a0 mode and this is what a
typical uh simulation of a guided wave
looks like
so uh remember i mentioned briefly the
need for baseline subtraction
so here you will see on the left it's a
signal without any damage
on the right you have a signal with
damage so you will see that the damage
signal is really really
incoherent or small
and that
that tells us that we need to be really
doing baseline subtraction if we want to
use this for damage detection or
localization
so with that background uh i'll talk
about the first task that uh
i have tackled that is damage detection
so why do we need to do damage detection
early on that is because it can reduce
structural structural
repair cost in the future
it can also avoid catastrophic failures
the only big real-time requirement is it
should be robust to the external
variations such as rainfall snowfall it
should be able to give a good detection
performance in spite of this external
variations
so the first challenge that we have with
this is there is a mismatch between what
the mathematical model tells us and what
the actual experimental data looks like
on the left side you see a simulated
wave from from the lam wave model
you can see the s0 and the a0 modes
pretty clearly in the simulated waveform
but on the right side you see actual
experimental data
and you'll see the s0 mode is
almost absent
the a0 mode is there but you also have
an extra reflection
and this comes because
the experimental data is generally taken
from a structure with some boundaries so
you have these reflections coming from
the boundaries
so this is the first challenge that we
have with guided waves there is a
mismatch between the theoretical model
and experimental data
the second big challenge we have is that
of the temperature variations
so what we are seeing here is
an illustration showing two waveforms at
two
different temperatures
so as you can see later in time the
there is a market difference between the
two waveforms and this is a big source
of uh challenge or
some
something we need to overcome for our
damage detection
so typical strategies for dealing with
temperature
they all
occur at the baseline subtraction stage
so one is you choose a baseline signal
from a bank of baseline signals taken at
different temperatures
another approach is
you stretch
the observed signal to match a baseline
signal
but these are all at the baseline
subtraction stage
and the typical approach to guided wave
damage detection one is you can use an
energy based method that is you compare
the energy of the two signals and
threshold it appropriately to give a
detection output
you can think of damage detection as a
binary classification damage
there are also likelihood models that is
you train
uh let's say a machine learning model
for doing damage localization based on
gaussian likelihood and then you
threshold the likelihood to give to also
give a detection output
but researchers have shown that
likelihood models can also assign
spurious values to out of distribution
inputs
so we ask the question can we cast
damage detection as an anomaly detection
problem
and
what we have is an approach for robust
guided wave damage detection
so the first point we have is ensemble
learning
we train an ensemble of variational auto
encoders that are initialized randomly
to enable robustness to the temperature
variations
second point is adversarial training
we train on simulation data with
adversarial perturbations the wave
number that is the uh dispersive
property of the wave
and finally the variational autoencoder
using that we can cast damage detection
as an anomaly detection problem
so some more details about using a
variational auto encoder
so
we train the va on baseline subtracted
data
so that is
uh let's say you have a structure with
some damage when you do baseline
subtraction ideally you are only going
to be left with the damage signal and
that is what we consider as in
distribution
and if there is no damage
after baseline subtraction
there is only going to be noise and the
noise signal there is a no domain no
damage signal is out of distribution
and the detection statistic that we use
is the output of the variational auto
encoder that is the elbow value
we
take its average over all the ensembles
and normalize it by the output dimension
so the output dimension is
let's say the number of time samples
times the number of sensor pair signals
that we have
so this is a normalized
value or detection statistic that i have
at the output
and this is a figure showing the entire
setup i know there are a lot of things
going here so let me try to break it
down
on the very left
we fixed the simulation parameters that
is the location of the sensor array
and we
use the lam way model in this blue box
here that is the simulation engine
we pass the data through some signal
processing and we do some signal
processing some filtering we do baseline
subtraction
and we generate random damage locations
over the plate dimensions and this helps
us to generate a data set of uh damage
signals and this forms the training data
and similarly we have an experimental
setup that is shown in the orange box
here that is
we
we uh observe that
observe the data over the sensors we do
some filtering the baseline subtraction
and we store that as the test data set
and finally the training data is
inputted to the ensembl of variational
auto encoders
and after the training process we get
this
detection statistic that is the
normalized
value of the loss function of the
vae
so here is a architecture of the va that
i use so compared to computer vision
task that is a this is a shallow network
but we have found that this works the
best for our task
we have two 1d convolutional layers at
the start followed by our dense layers
and then in the decoder phase of the va
we have the
transposed of the 1d convolutional
layers
so coming to the experimental setup
we have this plate of aluminium
of dimensions 1.2 times 1.2 meters
and this is exposed to non-uniform
temperature variations
so what we do is place a heater at some
point on this plate and that creates
non-uniform temperature variations
and the red diamond that you see here
that's the damage location
we collect 77 measurements over a
duration of 6 hours
and the damage is simulated by placing a
mass that has the same scattering effect
and it is placed from the 37th
measurement onwards
so you have some no damage samples and
you have some damage samples from this
experimental setup
now coming to this topic of how can we
quantify the effect of temperature at
least approximately
so typically researchers have
approximated temperature effect as a
time stretch operation
so if we consider two signals
x of t and s of t recorded at two
different temperatures
s of t can also be written as x of alpha
times t where alpha is some stretch
factor that needs to be estimated
and the optimal stretch factor is the
one that minimizes the residual energy
between the two signals at two different
temperatures
and the stretch factor is computed using
the scale transform which is a
variant of the fourier transform
and one interesting property about the
scale transform is
the time stretch a stretch in the time
domain is equal to a phase shift in the
frequency domain so this is similar to
the fourier transform property that a
delay in time domain is equivalent to a
phase shift in the frequency domain
so here is the illustration showing the
effect of temperature variations
so
here we have plotted the correlation
coefficient against the stretch factors
stretch factor
so um this is plotted for three
different signals again against one
reference signal
so if we look at the x axis here the
range is
0.998 to 1.003
so
so this range of stretch factor
corresponds to temperature variations of
4 degrees to 19 degrees celsius
and you can see that as the stretch
factor deviates from one the correlation
coefficient starts dropping
substantially
so this graph or this figure illustrates
what is the effect of temperature
variations on
the guided waves
so finally the detection performance
that we see with our ensemble
variational autoencoder approach
this is a histogram showing the
distinction between the damage and no
damage cases
so we see that the two uh distributions
for damage and no damage are well
separated
signifying robustness
but what about some numbers the actual
performance of the detection method that
we use
so we compare these four methods
one is an ensemble of
variational autoencoders trained with
adversarial data second is a ensemble of
va trained on ideal data that is without
any adversarial perturbations
then we have the likelihood model that
is a model train for some other
localization task for example that is
then
used for this detection
so we see that
the probability of false alarm
that is uh you have the the model
predicts that there is a damage when
there is actually no damage that is the
probability of false alarm so both the
likelihood models here they have a very
high probability of false alarm and that
is what researchers have shown to that
likelihood models assign spurious values
to out of distribution inputs
and the first two rows here that is the
ensemble va approach
show uh
a very uh probability of false alarm is
zero but you can see that when we train
the va with adversarial data we have a
high probability of detection that is
the network says there is a damage when
there is actually a damage
so we see that the va ensemble approach
when trained on adversarial data has
superior performance
so that was all about damage detection
now we move to the next task in
structural health monitoring that is
damage localization actually finding the
location of the damage
so traditional signal processing methods
have tried to solve this inverse problem
as
by solving multiple forward problems
so what we have is
the sensors are collecting some
measurements and you need to estimate
some unknown quantity that is the damage
location from these measurements
so we have a mathematical model and
by solving this mathematical model at
every grid point
you then correlate that with the
experimental data
so the point that gives the highest
correlation between the mathematical
model and the experimental data
is the estimated location
so on the right we have a figure called
as a ambiguity surface so that's
basically a heat map of the correlation
values
and this is to be noted is in ideal
conditions
so in in these conditions you can see
that the correlation value is actually
highest for the actual damage location
so this shows a good performance
but what happens in presence of the
temperature variations
it affects localization performance
substantially
so in this figure here we can see on the
top
that's ideal conditions
that's when the localization performance
is good but when we have environmental
variations temperature variations the
localization performance drops we can
see that
this region of high correlation
is uh diffused it's not a relate it's
not close to the actual damage location
so we can see that the localization
performance is affected by the
temperature variations
and as we discussed before there are
certain temperature compensation methods
such as choosing the right baseline
stretching the baseline signal
but all of them are at the baseline
subtraction phase and they do not
address the effect of these temperature
variations on the localization
algorithms
that is
maybe i want a metric of uncertainty in
the output location
how do i get that so that is one more
challenge that we have with localization
with that motivation
we ask the question can we use deep
learning for guided wave damage
localization
one
one potential
positive point is that deep neural
networks have been shown to learn
for a variety of scientific and
engineering tasks with comp complex or
complicated input data
and deep learning systems can be used in
can be used
in test time with a single forward pass
you can train the data you can train the
network offline and then just have it
predict using a single forward pass in
real time so that is one more advantage
that we have with deep learning
but there are challenges and those are
very critical challenges for this task
so the first is uh
any deep learning application needs
as much training data as it can have
right
so
but here we have the challenge that we
only have limited experimental data sets
we cannot go
around creating new specimens and then
breaking them with damages so that would
take a lot of time and efforts
so we need to find a way to bypass that
challenge
and then the second challenge is that
these temperature variations that we
have seen affect the detection and
localization performance
there needs to be a strategy of dealing
with those
external variations we need to show
robust performance even in the presence
of those variations
and finally as a
as an effect of these external
variations there is also going to be
uncertainty at the output
so how can we build better methods that
can
express the output uncertainty quantify
the output uncertainty
so uh
if if a deep network was trained in an
end-to-end manner this is how it would
look like you have this uh
input signals at the
at the input so we have this
guided wave signal and now it's not just
one signal you have the signals coming
from all the sensors so you have
multiple signals that can be inputted to
a deep network and that gives a location
prediction by minimizing the
distance between the true and predicted
damage locations
so this is what a typical uh deep
network process or framework would look
like
but we have these challenges that it
we also need to show or visualize the
output uncertainty
and for that we propose a framework
where we train on simulated data alone
simulated guided wave data and test on
experimental data
we also uh
enable robustness to the temperature
variations by train by using an ensemble
approach
and finally
as a result of this ensemble approach we
can also quantify the output uncertainty
as the ensemble standard deviation
so
here is a similar figure for
damage localization so as before
in this blue box we have the training
data generation process
where you have the lamb wave simulation
engine that is generating data for us
and for every data point you have a
random damage location
we do filtering we do baseline
subtraction to get the training data set
similarly we have the experimental setup
that gives us the experimental
observations and the
and then we train this ensemble of
neural networks that can give us
the final damage location prediction and
also the localization uncertainty
um here is a table showing the
uh network so the input is like i said a
matrix of size
uh let's say q cross m where q is the
length of the signal and m is the number
of sensor pairs we are using in our
setup
so typical sizes
for this for my experiment would be
1000 cross
56 that would say the
the length of the signal is thousand and
i have 56 sensor pairs
uh so eight sensors can lead to eight
into seven that is 56 sensor pairs
so those are my typical input sizes
and then i have two 1d convolutional
layers and then
four dense layers and finally the output
which gives the damage location
to compare my approach with
the existing methods
we have two approaches
so the delay and some imaging called as
das
that assumes that the wave travels with
a constant group wave velocity that is a
narrow band model and here
one note is that the performance depends
on the right choice of the group wave
velocity and that needs some domain
knowledge
and the second
method that i compare with is called as
match field processing mfp
and this uses a wideband model of wave
propagation and researchers have also
modified this approach using some data
driven methods such as compressed
sensing
but they need access to the test time
measurements
so the comparison metrics that i have
are the average localization error
and the resolution that is the half
amplitude width so basically
if you're talking about the ensemble
network i get this predictions from the
ensembl network i uh
i characterize that as a gaussian
distribution with some mean and standard
deviation and then i can
calculate the half amplitude width
and similarly for the
delay and sum and match field processing
i fit a gaussian curve to the normalized
ambiguity surface or the heat map figure
that we saw before
so here is a table
comparing the results so we can see our
proposed average shown in red here
it has
it has a superior performance
compared to the other methods for lower
number of sensors the black box here
shows the performance comparison for
eight sensors
and we can see our proposed approach has
much better performance
than the other methods
and
similarly our approach has comparable
performance for more number of sensors
so
so one note here is as i mentioned the
delay and sum
needs knowledge about the group wave
velocity
and the delay and the match field
processing the two
dd-mfp methods shown here they need
access to the test time measurements
on the other hand our ensemble network
is trained on simulated data alone
without the
without the need for any kind of
more knowledge needed
so here are some visual illustrations
showing
the different methods
so the this figure on the extreme left
and and the figure next to it those are
the two mfp methods and this is the
heat map that we have for
for these methods and this is with
simulated data in ideal conditions
so we can see that for almost all the
methods
the performance is good the the the
predicted damage location is close to
the true damage location that is the red
box that we are seeing here
and on the extreme right we have our
proposed approach the heat map for our
approach
and then what happens when we work with
actual experimental data now this is
where it gets interesting
we can see that for the the first three
figures here those are the
traditional methods match field
processing and delay and sum
so we can see that the performance the
localization performance
drops substantially the peak is not
localized
whereas we can see for our approach on
the extreme right
we have a
bigger region of uncertainty but uh the
the peak of the region is near the true
damage location
signifying
robust localization performance
and we also plot the
localization error versus the stretch
factor so to note here again the stretch
factor is a quantification of the degree
of uh temperature variations
so we can see that
our approach the red curve
has
a
comparatively better performance or
lower localization error for all the
stretch factors that we see in our
experimental data
and we see that there is no obvious
trend with the stretch factor values too
and this is where we vary the size of
the ensemble
and we can see that um as we go on
increasing the ensemble size
uh the localization error that is the
blue bar
it
it goes on
decreasing the localization error goes
on decreasing
but as we go above an ensemble size of
the marginal increase in performance
is
not not too big so that's why we fix the
size of our ensemble at 10.
and finally this is where we talk about
quantifying the output uncertainty
so this is with simulation data
i generate 100 test samples with random
damage locations and for each sample
we have a random stretch factor
that is sampled from a range of 0.99 to
1.01
so just to remind you in our
experimental data the stretch factor
variations were 0.998 to 1.003
and that corresponded to a temperature
range of 4 to 19 degrees celsius
so a range of 0.99 to 1.01 is even
bigger than that
so what we can see here is this is
we choose the uncertainty metric as the
mean of our standard deviation of the
ensemble predictions
so
what we can see here here is the
uncertainty metric plotted against the
stretch factor
and we can see that for stretch factor
close to 1 that is
ideal conditions the uncertainty metric
value is the least close to zero but as
we deviate from a value of one on both
sides the uncertainty value rises
so this serves as a good representation
of
or a good valid validation of our chosen
uncertainty metric
here is another
illustration that i have
so here i have generated a pattern in
the test samples
and they are stretched according to a
pattern of repeating values
so you can think of this as
there's a heater at some point and that
can be toggled in three different
conditions
off condition low condition and high
condition
so
the stretch factor has
three of distinct values 0.991 and 1.01
corresponding to three these three
hypothetical temperature conditions
and the interesting trend we see here is
when the stretch factor deviates from 1
that is when the uncertainty metric the
blue curve here also has high values for
both uh for deviations from 1 both in in
the
in the direction of 0.99 as well as in
1.01
but when the stretch factor is close to
1 here
that's when the uncertainty metric value
is also the lowest
so
this is similar to the earlier figure we
saw that as we deviate from a stretch
factor of 1 from the ideal condition the
uncertainty value also rises
so here are the results for the
experimental data
and uh we can see here slightly similar
trends
uh in the figure on the right we have
the
the stretch factor that is showing in
oscillatory behavior
so that is what
was
presented in our experimental setup a
fan that was oscillating between
different conditions
and the uncertainty metric value the
blue curve
shows trends similar to before that is
when the stretch factor deviates from 1
the uncertainty metric value is high and
when the stretch factor is close to 1
the uncertainty metric value also drops
so um to conclude
what we have proposed here are
machine learning networks for two tasks
of damage detection and damage
localization using guided waves
so our approach has multiple advantages
first is we train on simulated data
alone and test on
actual experimental data
and secondly we have these robustness to
temperature variations that can occur in
a real time setup and we tackle that we
attack we tackle those temperature
variations using an ensemble approach
we have superior performance
in the lower sensor regime compared to
the other signal processing methods
and finally as a result of using the
ensembl approach we can also quantify
the output uncertainty
what is next for us we want to do a
sensitivity analysis that is how do
different factors of input variations
affect the detection and localization
performance that is
i can change the number of sensors i can
change the positioning of the sensor
area i can put them all in one corner of
the structure or in a random location
and see how that affects the performance
and
i need to do this in a simulation phase
i cannot do it on the testing phase
because the time and money is limited so
how can i set up a
framework for that
and finally
how can i extend this approach to
different structure geometries so in the
experimental setup i explained before we
had a plate of
square dimensions but how can we extend
that to more complex geometries
and those are all the points that we
want to tackle in the future
this is the work so far or
what we are currently doing
and this is our smart data lab at
university of florida
all excellent researchers and
here is our pi professor joel harley who
has a lot of
varied research interests
and thank you so much for listening to
my talk and i'd be happy to answer any
questions that anyone in the audience
has thank you
all right thank you so much for the
wonderful talk uh ishaan
so let's have a q a sessions um
anyone has any questions
i don't see any questions in q and a
chat
in in chat room
um let me
while you are thinking about the
questions i can
ask some
qualification questions if you go to
slide nine
um
[Music]
yeah so so you said in a without damage
and b with dimensions and
basically
from my eyeball norm i that looks the
same
yeah
so what do you mean by bass lines
obstructions
and
yeah how do you
yeah i mean
yeah so um
so this this figure on the left that is
without any damage in the structure and
this figure on the right is
with the damage um so baseline
subtraction is so as as i explained here
uh the received signal in at the sensor
is a combination of these two signals
the direct signal that is traveling from
the transmitter to the receiver and the
damage signal that is traveling
from the transmitter to the damage to
the receiver
so baseline subtraction removes this
direct signal
and keeps only the damage signal
so uh so this is before we do any
baseline subtraction
but once we do baseline subtraction we
are left with only the damage signal
and um
how does it look like the damage signal
um so it looks similar to the lamb wave
that we have here uh in the figure b
here and and then
for that the damaged one
and not damaged ones are
clearly distinguishable yeah so if there
is no damage and we still do baseline
subtraction ideally we would be left
only with noise
and if there is damage we would see a
signal like this
i see
all right great
um
is there any other questions from
audience
well if not i have another question if
you go to slide 11
you seems to
know
which one is a0 mode and feature one is
as serial mode and which one is
reflections
as on
non-experts
i cannot tell which one is a0 mode and
which is zero mode this one is
reflection it looks like a
a0 mode on the right is s0 mode and then
reflection
is a0 mode and
so
so with every mode uh there is a
velocity associated
so
yeah so with this so this is known by
the domain experts and you're right that
it's hard for a
different person to understand it so the
so different modes travel with different
velocities
so you kind of know when to expect a
particular mode based on the velocity
right
i see and if you don't see the signals
then you you determine that there is no
s series
yes yes right got it got it okay so if
you go to slide 18
you said uh um
you use um shallow
net shell on your on that and you
you found it that's the best right
in terms of what and did you try other
neural net or what else did you try
so
so in terms of the actual detection or
localization performance
we we found the networks to be of around
this size to perform the best
so
some um some other alternatives that i
tried was
just having a very a bigger network with
more number of layers
or having different number of
frequencies in the input or different
number of sensor pairs
so
what we found out is
obviously for different number of sensor
pairs you need to appropriately increase
the size of your hidden layers
to to be able to
accurately process the all the
information
um
yeah and i think that was
the
experiments that we did in trying to
determine this
size of the neural network
did you um did you use any
neural net architecture search
tools
um
no like hyper hyper
and
oh no no
a tune
yeah
you might be
you might want to use those tools
in order to
save some time
right right
all right uh
okay there is a question by phillip in
the chat
he asked
how well will this method adapt to
different real systems such as aircraft
bridges and buildings etc
yeah that's a very important question
because we
ultimately want this to be
applicable to some real world setup so
the experiments that we do and a lot of
researchers in this field do is
with a
square plate or or something of that
sort
and and it's actually a very
uh challenging
problem to be able to transfer that to
some of these complex structures like
aircrafts bridges or buildings but there
are certain
transfer learning methodologies that
researchers are trying to come up with
that removes any kind of dependence on
the structure i mean i could train
uh us
a network for structure a and try to
make it applicable to structure b
but that is something
we have not tried out in this work but
we can try out later
thank you for the question
okay sounds good
is there any other question from
audiences
okay um if you don't mind going a slide
29.
all right so the basically the blue
spark that's the like
your physics simulation your model yes
yes and on the top and
that is the experimental yes data the
orange one and then you
the physics simulation use it as a trend
data and the experimental data you use
it as a testing
yes and then you you you you train the
uh
the 10 different neural net here
yes right and then
you know collect all the all the results
and
and based on some distributions you try
to find the mean and standard deviations
yes that's right
um but uh all the neural net um is
getting the exactly identical inputs
like for the testing and training
yeah yeah so the only difference is the
weight in the weight initialization of
the ensemble networks
so that result was surprising to us also
that and the neural net architectures
are all the same
yes
the only thing different is um the
dropout probabilities that we use and
the weight initializations
so one explanation that some researchers
have is
this ensemble approach explores
different
modes in the lost landscape
that helps to achieve a robust
performance
yeah so so at the end of the day the
mean and standard deviations you
you you quantify
that also is coming from the neural net
yes
the initialization seed
itself
yes
yes i'm not sure how to interpret those
uncertainty um
interesting
yeah so um
so i think we can think of the
uncertainty as um
the conditional uncertainty right so
given
given this input we we have this output
with so and so
uh probability or the standard deviation
yeah but those inputs and inputs are all
the identical and architectures are all
identical
except the initial initial gas for
wooden old and neural nets
yeah so you're kind of trying to um
you know to quantify the uncertainty in
neural net training in some sense
that could be one way of looking at it
so i think what you're trying to get at
is can we actually get the input
uncertainty to propagate to the output
yeah yeah exactly yeah
okay
we have this adversary perturbations at
the input that
simulates some of the temperature
variation behavior
yeah that actually if you do that then
then you may
include the uncertainty i mean that when
you quantify the uncertainty you are
uh you are counting those uncertainty
but this very setting
i think you only want to find
uncertainty from the neuron that
training
all right um is there any other
questions from audiences
i that was all the older questions i
have
well i mean
another comment i would make
another project i'm i'm very
you know involved right now is the
earthquake
source
location detection
right
so there um
[Music]
we
try to simulate the real altc
thingy with the simulation and then
generate the
beta and there is some sensors on the
on the ground
and we
measure those displacement velocity etc
and then using only those sensors
measured data we try to
find out the
location of the earth source location
there we used
a machine learning technique we haven't
quantified any uncertainty it was all
the deterministic way i think some of
your methodology is applicable to
earthquake
uh project um i'm working on right now
that is great
all right
if we do not have any more questions
let's thank our speaker ishan thank you
so much for the wonderful talk and
giving
and giving a talk i i understand that
you will have a the defense
of your phd defense next month right um
so good luck with that
and i'm sure you will pass
right
all right
thank you
have a good day
bye bye thank you thank you everyone for
joining
oh
[Music]